Hello there!
You read the headlines, right?
OpenAI image recognition software fooled,
OpenAI deceived or openai discovers its visual
AI can be fooled by written notes and so on,
it even made it into The Guardian.
These are just a few search results when you
google OpenAI fooled.
In this video we will discuss who the fool
here really is.
Is the media trying to make fools of us with
these clickbait headlines?
Or... is OpenAIs model fooled by a handwritten
label on an object?
Or are we all fooled a little and are misusing
terminology here?
So, to determine this, we first have to know
what this is all about.
It all started with OpenAI releasing their
CLIP model.
If you want to know all about CLIP, watch
Ms. Coffee Bean’s explanation on it first.
In a nutshell, it is a large model trained
on lots and lots of data that can predict
similarities between image and text.
So image-text similarity scores is the model’s
goal, this is what it was trained for.
But it does this image-sentence similarity
task so well, that we can go a little beyond
it and engineer textual prompts such that
CLIP starts to look like an image recognition
classifier instead, that tells you only one
label about the image.
But because the model was not trained exactly
on this data and on this objective of image
recognition, we call this setting zero-shot
testing if we didn't do any fine-tuning further.
And for the rest of the discussion in this
video, there was no fine-tuning involved.
So CLIP’s weights are already published
and everybody is building cool applications
with CLIP, just look at this whole Reddit
post enumerating some of them (find the link
below).
Then in the middle of this hype, OpenAI publishes
a next blog post called “Multimodal Neurons
in Artificial Neural Networks” which contains
a lot of interesting stuff.
Read it, or watch Yannic’s video on this.
And there, in this blogpost it is!
The authors discover the what they call typographic
attacks.
They take an image and let CLIP predict the
similarity to these labels.
It’s zero-shot, the model did not see this
data and image recognition setting before,
but it is still able to predict the apple
and its variety correctly.
I did not even know about Granny Smith apples
before.
Then they just paste a textual label onto
the apple and OMG here it is!
CLIP now assigns highest similarity to iPod,
it's just reading the text!
How silly!
It's an attack, it's an adversarial attack
in the wild, crazy!
CLIP is fooled by pen and Teller!
Oh, haha I mean pen and paper.
Wow, it's such an adversariality, I mean the
god of war himself loves it!
Ok, calm down Ms. Coffee Bean.
Yes, the authors themselves call it an attack.
Then it must be an attack, CLIP is fooled,
case closed.
Well, not so quick there!
Let’s think about it a little.
CLIP was trained to predict image-sentence
similarity scores, not object probabilities.
It was also not trained explicitly for image
recognition, even if it solves it zero-shot.
It was trained for predicting a similarity
score between images and rich textual formulations
and it does exactly this also in zero-shot
testing.
There is a lot of iPod in this image, honestly.
A real adversarial example would be to predict
iPod when there is no iPod to be seen there.
But a large portion of this image is the word
iPod!
So what is wrong?
For Ms. Coffee Bean it is worrisome how we
misname the whole situation calling this an
"adversarial attack": CLIP does not do anything
wrong, it does what it was trained to do:
It predicts similarities between given images
and textual prompts with a little too much
obsession for text, that’s true.
So we actually changed it’s objective from
predicting image-text similarity where recognizing
text is encouraged, to predicting image-concept
similarity where reading text is discouraged.
And we do this suddenly and without training
or specifying this modification, so we suddenly
want it to ignore the text.
Misusing “adversarial” for
an objective misalignment implies that it
is the model’s fault for making silly mistakes;
even that we were witty enough to “fool”
it.
But Ms. Coffee Bean thinks that we are the
fools using the model irresponsibly: If we
would use CLIP in a self-driving car scenario,
it would be really bad if it was fooled by
such labels writtten on pen and paper, but
we would be the fools using a model that was
trained to predict image-sentence similarity
to do something so different like categorizing
objects in a self-driving car setting.
Even if the model is so powerful zero-shot,
it does not mean that its objective is aligned
with the new task we want solved without further
training.
We are hiding our foolishness by “adversarial
attacks” and blame the model alone, which
is dangerous and distracting, like we were
even clever enough to come up with an adversarial
example against it, but it was actually us
misusing the model the whole time.
But Ms. Coffee Bean did not make a whole video
to complain about misusing terminology, this
happens in Machine Learning all the time!
And of course the press picks up on this.
She rather wants to raise awareness that this
whole situation where we are actually the
fools expecting models to change their training
behavior in zero-shot applications, will become
more and more frequent.
The number of self-supervised, general-purpose
models is on the rise.
Just see latest post by Yann leCun and Ishan
Misra.
But even if the models are general-purpose
and self-supervised, they are still supervised,
they have an objective enforced by the loss
function defined by us, when we are defining
the self-supervision task.
In case of CLIP, it is sentence-image similarity.
But the trap with these models is to think
that they compute such general representations
and do so well applied without modification
to new tasks, that we can use them on anything.
But the model in zero-shot, will try to solve
the objective it was trained to do.
CLIP was exposed a lot during training to
text and it maximizes its text-image similarity
objective, if it develops representations
enabling it to read -- and it does.
When we misuse this reading capability for
an adversarial attack, when we actually just
suddenly changed the objective to image recognition,
we are not fooling CLIP.
Just as an analogy: If CLIP was a car, we
would drive of a cliff with it and while falling
down we would cry: Adversarial attack!
Why can the car not fly?
It can do so many other things!
Well, especially with general-purpose models
we have to be aware of the objective alignment
problem because the new objective we give
the model during zero-shot testing does not
necessarily align with its training objective.
Expecting CLIP not to read the text in the
image, is like taking some medicine without
reading the receipt and the side effects of
that medicine.
But here is the hook with the general-purpose
models like CLIP: So far all of them are trained
on so much data that nobody can keep track
of it and one can never fully write the receipt
of the CLIP medicine.
One more reason not to blindly buy these general-purpose
models and apply them zero-shot to everything
because yes, there will be a lot of surprise
responses that are adversarial to our goal.
But when the model fails like in this case
with CLIP, where it just reads the label,
because CLIP was exposed to OCR (which is
Optical Character Recognition) during training,
then it is not an attack, we do not fool it,
but we have attacked ourselves by applying
a model we do not know that much about for
a new task, which is misaligned to the training
objective and the data that the model has
seen during training.
So it is very good that the attention to these
typographic attacks (which are not really
attacks) have been brought to the public for
at least two more reasons: Firstly, it is
worrisome how much CLIP focuses on rendered
text compared to the rest of the image.
So instead of an adversarial attack, I think
the authors have discovered an obsession which
can be easilly explained by the optical character
recognition exposure during training.
But there is good news: one can also fix it
by fine-tuning, but the question is by how
much?
Or by giving to CLIP some more options, see
Yannic’s experiment on this linked below.
To CLIP’s further defense, it also assigns
some probability to the apple still.
But remember, the model can tell its opinion
only about what is in the answer possibilities.
The other worrisome thing, is that the textual
affinity and especially other undiscovered
affinities of CLIP could and most certainly
will be exploited by attackers also when machine
learning engineers would try to reformulate
CLIPs objective during fine-tuning, so with
further training.
A little different from the zero-shot testing
we discussed so far.
It is very unclear how much of the “obsessions”
of pre-training go into fine-tuning or not.
So adversarial or not, we do not think anybody
will care too much about all this and we guess
everybody will keep using the term "adversarial
attack" when they actually mean "objective
misalignment between pre-training and zero-shot
application".
Misusage of terminology also happens with
other sexy terms like zero-shot, generative
modelling just to name a few, and who knows,
adversarial attacks will eventually completely
change their meaning.
But at least we hope that now YOU know where
all these headlines about fooling OpenAIs
model come from.
Of course it is the model’s fault, we fool
it, we are so clever and we have never misused
a model, we promise!
How about liking and subscribing to fool the
YouTube algorithm into thinking that Ms. Coffee
Bean is famous and fun to watch!
Okay bye!